me is considered to be one of the best
or the best tekken player in the world
today
he started to gain popularity in playing
brian in the previous tekken games
but now in tekken 7 he is known to be a
god in every single character
[Music]
with his stylish gameplay and
unpredicted character picks there's no
question that knee adds more excitement
to tekken tournaments every time he
plays oh my god he picked lily again
here are some of the best moments in
tekken tournaments when me hyped up the
crowd looking oh my god oh my god
this is
no word trip the crowd just exploded no
words
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so good with the electric
[Music]
uh
putting on the hurt
so good oh good
stop saying that
so you guys saw that neither god
[Music]
oh they're cheering for brian oh my god
he's going to give it to him the
murderer
brian
finally picked by me
finishes the string
pocket fighting back
oh big counter that should be around you
should be able to pull it out here
oh it hasn't met the wall gonna have to
be careful here
oh
three times do it again
[Music]
[Applause]
trying to keep it mixed up oh do it
again oh he gets the low punish oh
about 30 seconds left on the clock oh he
blocked it
oh wow
he's trying to catch him 20 seconds left
what is about to happen this battle is
about to explode
in a goddamn ridiculous set wow versus
tata
wow
wow
wow again
[Music]
okay
yes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
for right now we're gonna find out who
is gonna be
our what the oh let's go i can't i mean
i'm so excited to see no way his brian
but of course chanel pulling out goku
akuba
this is good
what teleport towards this jet up or
please oh yeah i think he was just
trying to get out he thought he was
going to go in oh my goodness you don't
okay
let's go
he's back yeah he's back
yeah but he got that muscle memory for
it you know oh get out nice 5-14 and
that's the great thing about hey ryan
against akuma is any tatsu he'll be able
to get the jet up for afterwards
uh-huh three rounds straight again and
chanel's like oh coward low for himself
and he's got beer to spend
there it is to the wall sidewalk left
though the better oh the knee wakes him
up
okay what's he gonna do does it take
roll this time he's gotta get out he's
waiting for him oh my gosh he cornered
himself
with the punish is that gonna be enough
should be get out of here
knee with the comeback
2-0
damn who's going to take it this is so
intense
the music doesn't help
too crazy
but that's going to be
this out oh my goodness
the big counter hit
between the characters oh oh my god
look at the damage he's all standing
damage before because he was on his back
yeah with a full one two one two series
here gets punished there they get a 14.
not looking good for chanel right now
[Music]
oh what a duck
just pull the trigger anything heavy
[Music]
the loads you have
smart stuff me and now he
oh big back one oh this is going to be
close it's not going to be enough to
kill should be very very close though
and the oaky behind it
the second hit
[Music]
me is your champion for evo japan 2018
the legend is back
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it's feeding each other out of
these stages
oh my gosh sending a message right now
in round one of the holy mole amazing
the brine guards going at it man i know
they are indeed here out in the cold
snow
cycle
wow
kicks in a row into kickoff
[Music]
dominant ryan fury wow clearly ownership
details here by lee mr knapp wants to
keep him at the wall and there's a
counter it from me
downstairs down we go
down we go that's it let's do it and it
is over macbreaker
[Music]
no funny business getting the kill here
oh
yeah 18. and then
shoot the ball
and he's given these around
gave it away
the magic four encounters that's so hard
to pull up
he wants to talk to finish he is baiting
right now there's a hatchimal and
another one
and he does the rager and takes it three
games oh my dave finishes the last game
three rounds to zero
jimmy tran not his head and shakes his
hand what a showdown we have just
witnessed here with lee versus jimmy
tran
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right now and now knee with rage
calls deadly with rage just a single jab
combo trying to keep him out here
okay it's a little cheap demo man one
more guess
oh wow found a piece who's taking a leap
you got something 10 seconds like just
about either one of these guys great
[Applause]
drive knock it happen
corners go forward three four knees
these guys know he's still alive
final match of the group play coming up
and this is a doozy kacoma versus d
who's going home let's go yeah he's
trying to get stepping punish there's
the wall flat realignment get the side
step he can get the double wall splat
oh god he can't look he's gonna get him
something crazy
[Music]
here's the combo he dropped sander the
launcher misses the punish
oh
my god this is falling apart for kacoma
on the perfect and he gets it to
eliminate kakova
knee makes it in to the top eight here
at twt
2018. that was terrifying
guys make some noise for neat
crowd in support
[Music]
three
if you ever had questions what a no
round brown looks like you just got
educated this is crazy
i cannot believe what i'm seeing steve i
cannot believe it
demolishing me do that you always think
it's good again oh the phoenix is
me
[Music]
oh my gosh got it backed up attica
getting ready to come back oh
blue stuff
now
can he close out with this i don't think
so i don't think so
no big bad here's the block full tackle
for the pressure oh
now oh my god yeah blocking the blue
defense here we go can he stay on the
board no duck in the high there and me
staying in the round trying to go two
zero on the reason red final and it
doesn't
we're all caught up don't put him away
just kill him just kill him you got to
make sure this next combo
oh now oh crap
oh good stuff from the low period he
doesn't have rage so that damage
oh it's enough damage though and it's
turning and here we go
oh ankles down again
and we got a small lead here not enough
to matter need now being patient
chopping away
for me he's been so good at it here's
the school attempt not gonna reach the
wall this time every small perry has
been pivotal for me right now
[Applause]
[Music]
is your combo breaker champion
yo guys yo guys y'all gonna tell me that
one good though y'all gonna tell me that
one good though it's okay it's all right
round of applause everybody no no no
let's make this count
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]